after the call to 911 the cops and the
coroner had gone things must be put back
in order even when things will never
ever be the same it's gruesome work but
someone's got to George when a life ends
in the worst possible way in the
vicinity of Maryland or Washington DC
it's often a cue for Louise Burkhart to
start work Louise excels at a job few
want and even fewer could stand to do I
go out to scenes of homicide suicide
decomposed remains or any kind of
biological incident and clean up and
restore it to the situation that it was
prior to the incident occurring the
first thing we do obviously is we
observe the situation because every
situation is totally different today
we're dealing with a suicide floor sorry
to meet you like this that's okay
keeping the lady that we're dealing with
her husband committed suicide and they
had three children basically what I'm
gonna do is go in look at everything
after I see exactly what we have to deal
with and we'll go ahead and start
working okay thank you very much
now Louise must grapple with the horrors
that lie beyond the bedroom door she
focuses on the process took it all in
and what I'm gonna do is pull the other
sheet so we can wrap it on that they
must look closely what seems to be a
tiny stain may be masking a hidden mass
of residue what it does is it which
store when it can be larger underneath
that it is from the top surface if we
can't properly clean something obviously
we have to remove it dispose of it it's
medical waste
sometimes the crew must remove threats
to health
other times they try to shield survivors
from even more heartbreak we take
high-powered lights and check and
recheck and recheck to make sure that we
have everything so that when the family
comes in they don't have to deal with
something unexpected we're looking for
if there was any overspray of blood any
tissue teeth um it could be anything
there's times where you found body
actual body parts whether it be a nose
or somebody they shot themselves it's
their eye you have to search everything
you know in the area to make sure that
there isn't anything left behind Louise
has been cleaning up after death for 11
years it's a profitable business lately
her son Mac has been helping his mom in
the field to support herself and her
children Louise started out working on
contract with the local medical
examiner's office transporting bodies we
started having people ask us when it was
a homicide or a suicide wall could you
clean this up and to be honest with you
I didn't think I could
however I turned around and at one point
I said yeah I won't give it a shot and
we tried it but we still thought it
would just be a little sigh it was a
little sideline kind of thing did not
expect that there was much of a need but
the market for post-mortem cleanup crews
grew with surprising speed the new niche
dovetailed with a sideline of Louise's I
had another business a regular maid
service and I have to say that if you're
gonna be cleaning for a lemon this is
definitely more satisfying than being a
maid amid her heavy schedule with its
inherent sadness Louise tries to stay
upbeat the best part of my job is having
people say what a difference we made
people really have gratitude for what
you do
after they're in those situations they
realize what it would be like if they
had to do it and they're really grateful
[Music]
you